دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قال حاكم
دونيتك الموالي لروسيا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تستهدفت منطقه بترو فيسكي بست
قذائف مدفعيه هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
قالت ان قوتها الجويه شنت خلال الساعات
الماضيه 25 غاره على مواقع القوات الروسيه
ومنظوماتها الصاروخيه في اكثر من جبهه
الهيئه اكد تدميرها طائره هجوميه روسيه
واستهداف ثلاث نقاط تحكم روسيه ومستودعيني
للذخيره كما اكد الجيش الاوكراني ان القوه
الروسيه سنه اكثر من 68 هجوما صاروخيا على
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه في مقاطع
وكانت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه قالت ان
الجيش الروسيه سنه هجوما صاروخيا على
مدينه باخ موت ومحيطها في مقاطعه زومبا
صاروخيه نفذت هجمات وصفتها بالدقيقه
استهدفت مواقع لتجمع القوات الروسيه
ومخازن اسلحه ومراكزه انظمه دفاع جوي
روسيا
حول
الصمادي
اذا تطورات جدا لافته على الصعيد الروسي
فيما يتعلق
تكسبه وتجني وتخسره القوات الروسيه ما هي
اخر المواقف من موسكو لو سمحت
اه يعني لو تحدثنا عن تطورات الوضع
الميداني ليلى يعني هنا اود الاشاره الى
التصريحات الاخيره التي صدرت صباح اليوم
من قبل السلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا
في دانيسكو التي تحدثت عن ان اييي القصف
الاوكراني مستمر لاحياء ومدن ودنيتك
والمقاطعه الثانيه الحديث يدور عن مقتل
مدني واصابه اخر جروح امس تم ااا او لقيت
امراه حتى اربعه اخرون اصيبوا بجروح اول
امس كان هناك طفل اصيب بجروح وقبل ذلك
الطفل الاخر القصف الاوكراني بحسب
التصريحات الرسميه مستمر للاحياء ويطال
العديد من المدنيين بشكل يومي همم فضلا عن
ذلك همم القصف الاوكرانيا المستمر في
يستمر في التسبب باضرار كبيره للبنيه
التحتيه في المنطقه على سبيل المثال خلال
اليوم الماضي اشاره السلطات ان القصف
الاوكراني طال 10 احياء سكنيه قصفت باكثر
من 50 مره في اكثر من 330 قد- قذيفه ود-
وذلك القصف بتسبب بتدمير العديد من
المباني السكانيه ومنشات اخرى تابعه
للبنيه التحتيه في المقاطعه همم ايضا كانت
هناك ليله امس تصريحات لافته صادره من قبل
السلطات في مقاطعه زاكولوجيا هناك ايضا
قائمه القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه باستهداف
مقر قيادي ولكن هذا المقر كان يضم في وقت
القصف كان هناك طابور من المدنيين يقف
للحصول على تصاريح لعبور الحافلات
والسيارات وهذا القصف على ما يبدو طال هذا
الطابور والمباني السكنيه المتخمه للمقر
متى سبب بمقتل خمسه مدنيين واصابه 10 همم
مدنيين اخرين بجروح هذا فيما يتعلق بالوضع
الانساني والميداني وعلى الصعيد يعني
التدمير البنا التحتيه في هذه المناطق اما
على الصعيد العسكريه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن خسائر كبيره في ارواح القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه خلال العمليات العسكريه التي
نفذتها اليوم الماضي الحديث يدور عن
القضاء على نحو 400 عسكري اوكراني وذلك
خلال يوم واحد الليله فضلا عن ذلك هناك
عمليات هجوميه تستمر القوات المسلحه
الروسيه بشنها في عدد من المحاور الحديث
يدور هنا بالدرجه الاولى عن محور خاركف
حيث تم القضاء امس هناك على نحو 40
اوكرانيا عن محور الكرام هناك تم القضاء
على اكثر من 150 اخرين وفي دانيسك تم
القضاء على 100 وفي المحور الجنوبيه من
الدنس على نحو 180 اذا خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه همم بحسب تصريحات ومعطيات
الرسميه الصادر بالنسبه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه كبيره للغايه فضلا عن ذلك نعم
نبقى في ذات الاطار نسال تامر همم اصمدي
ينضم الينا الان من كيف عن الموقف
الاوكراني ماذا تقول همم القوات
الاوكرانيه عن انجازاتها طالما ان الجانب
الروسي يتحدث عن خسائر كبيره في صفوف
الاوكرانيين
تمام عبد السلام الحقوات الاوكرانيه
وتحديد هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه منذ يومين
وهي تتحدث عن خسائر بالمئات للقوات
الروسيه بين قتلى وجرحى في مقاطعه زبرجيا
بالاضافه الى خيرسون وعدد من المناطق
الشرقيه البلاد يوم امس تحدثت عن همم اكثر
من 260 قتيلا في صفوف وجريحا ايضا في صفوف
القوات الروسيه في تركماك ميليتوبيل في
زبروجه واليوم ايضا تقول بانها تكثف من
قصفها لمواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه هناك
تتحدث عن خسائر وهذه الخسائر تتحدث عنها
بشكل متتالي واتباعا وتتحدث ايضا عن قصف
متواصل للقوات الروسيه مواقع مركزيه في
العديد من نقاط التماس عند ضفتينها دينيبر
في خيرسون وايضا بالعوده الى زبرج عمده
الاوكراني ليلى الماضي يتحدث عن قصف قاعده
مرك يعني اداره العمليات في احدى مناطق
زباروجيا وقال بان الحديث عن قتلى وجرحى
وبانه ينتظر الاعلان الرسمي عن الخسائر من
همم هيئه الاركان لكن في غضون ذلك يستمر
القصف الروسي على العديد من
المقاطعات الجنوبيه تحت تحديدا بالصواريخ
وفي المدفعيه خلال الساعات الماضيه تجدد
القصف على المناطق الساحليه في مقاطعه
ميكولايت جنوبيه البلاد الحديث عن منطقه
اوتشاكو بالاضافه الى القصف المتواصل
بالمدفعيه وبايه القذائف
بقذائف الهاون على مدينه خيرسون وعلى
العديد من القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خطا
التماس خلال دقائق الاخيره تحدثت القياده
العسكريه في غير سون عن اكثر من 40 هجوما
خلال الساعات الماضيه نفذتها القوات
الروسيه على المناطق المدنيه في خير صور
وتحدثت عن استهداف مباشر فواضح لابنيه
التحتيه ما ادى الى مواصله الانقطاعات في
الكبيره في الحقيقه في التيار الكهربائي
وفي المياه في المناطق السكنيه وهو ايضا
ما دفع السلطات المحليه هناك الى تجديد
مطالباتها للسكان بضروره النزوح الى
مقاطعات وسط وغرب اوكرانيا الاقل تضررا
بالحرب ايضا القصف يتواصل على المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه في
الحديث عن اكثر من ثلاثه عشر قريه وبنطقه
وبلده خلال الساعات الماضيه وفجر هذا
اليوم تعرضت لقصف روسي مكثف وفقا للاداره
العسكريه همم في زبروجه لكن نهايه عبد
السلام التطورات السياسيه متواصله الرئيس
الاوكراني خرج خلال الساعات الماضيه وتحدث
عن مساعدات عسكريه فرنسيه وحتى الاوروبيون
او الاوروبيين على مزيد من المساعدات وقال
بان الجيش الاوكراني لا يدافع فقط
مقبلات تامر وشمادي من كيف شكرا جزيلا لك
رانيا تريدي هنت معنا من موسكو شكرا لكم